- Well, we've talked about this before,
but you started acting when
you were pretty young, right?
- Yeah.
- I kind of heard crazy stories of like
how you used to be like young
and like travel to New York,
like without parents.
- Yeah, so I grew up in Maine
and I started auditioning for
like Broadway shows and stuff,
when I was like 10 and around,
and basically that would mean my parents
would have to drive me
like five hours to New York
for like one audition and then come home,
which was just not sustainable.
You know, they both worked full time.
And so eventually like around 12,
my brother was like 14 and they were like,
you guys can get on a Greyhound
bus and go to New York city
and come back and you'll be fine.
- Not a Dateline special
in the waiting at all.
Yeah, no.
- But yeah. So when I went and
auditioned for high society,
which was the show that I
eventually did, they, you know,
get on a Greyhound bus with my brother,
I auditioned and they're like, okay.
So we want to call you back
for tomorrow. Very exciting.
And they were like, so we'll,
we'll see you tomorrow.
And I was like, yes, you will.
Because I live here. Totally.
Absolutely.
I'm not a homeless street
rat running around the
streets of New York.
So my parents like faxed a credit card,
a copy of the credit card to a hotel.
And they were like, our
children will be checking in
and then we'll be along shortly
because obviously we're
not terrible parents
who've let them go to New York.
- Oh my gosh, I love your parents.
- And so we were like, you know, walk in.
And we're like, yes, our
parents will be along shortly.
And like, we're like,
wash our socks and underwear in the sink.
And then like, just go
back in the next day.
And like just all the
while pretending like, yes,
I am a totally normal person
who lives here and I'm not.
- I just came from my home.
- Yeah.
- Your brother's awesome, to
take you to the, it's so cool.
- It's so cool.
We're not gonna applause for my brother.
- And I mean, that's just so funny,
cause like when you have kids,
I'm going to ask you if
you would allow your kid.
Cause I would never allow
my kids to do what I did
when I was young.
- I wouldn't even allow
my kids to be sick on me
the way that you were.
- I know, you would.
- So, maybe I'd be the kind
of person who would be like
have fun, sweetie, bye.
Good luck.